bonjour alors cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret je vous recommande pour
les plus jeunes spectateurs à partir de
2 ans et demi trois ans on va dire un
programme d'animation en stop-motion
pâte et matt des ménages donc voilà
c'est l'histoire de deux bricoleurs un
peu maladroit qui vont poser leurs
cartons dans une nouvelle maison et ils
vont trouver plein de solutions
créatives pour faire face aux petits
défis de leur quotidien
donc c'est une série qui nous vient de
république tchèque
en fait ça vient donc des années 80 il
ya une série qui est passé à la télé qui
a eu un grand succès et ils ont été
repris dans les années 2000 donc et
modernisé voilà là c'est un programme de
34 minutes donc c'est vraiment adapté
pour les plus jeunes spectateurs et il
ya 5 5 films d'animation avec pleins de
gags burlesques et très loufoque voilà
c'est pour les plus jeunes à l'espace
noir et cette semaine et je rappelle que
c'est dans le cas de notre saison jeune
public donc vous avez les dates bien en
avant si vous voulez réserver vos places
pour venir en famille
[Musique]
m